okay so for me first of all if you have
nothing if you're building from zero the
first thing is pull-up bars a pull-up
bar and a dip bar somewhere to do dips
and somewhere to do pull-ups and that's
what you need now be careful if you're
listening and you're like okay I'm gonna
go buy a pull-up bar in a dip bar don't
get the little flimsy looking things
that cost one hundred and twenty nine
dollars do you don't want that
it's almost worthless it's better than
nothing but is almost worthless you want
to get a legit dip bar the legit pull-up
bar dip bars are a little bit easier you
can go you can go pretty cheesy on dip
bars but pull-up bars you can't pull-up
bars you need something legit strong you
can bolt it to your wall but you need a
nice pull-up bar with a with a inch and
a half or a two inch metal pipe I still
have a pull-up bar that I bought from
Home Depot I bought it in 1998 I've had
it ever since and it's bolted on to my
squat rack but that's all it is a piece
of you know two-inch pipe and that's
what you do pull-ups on so when you say
make sure it's legit why is that so you
don't so it doesn't break while you're
using it basically yeah and also it's
gotta have some weight to it so you can
do kipping pull-ups so you're not the
things not shaking all over the place
you get you see these I mean this is
just going total cheese ball the things
with like the foam handles that just
rotate and fall off and they're just
it's just a nightmare you want what you
need is a pipe that's what you need is a
piece of pipe from Home Depot and and
then you need somewhere to do dips now
one thing that you can do that will
cover both these is you can get rings
you know gymnastics rinks and you can
have you can adjust the height of the
rings and you can do dips and pull-ups
on rings and then you can do muscle ups
as well so rings are also like if
there's one thing you could have if you
can have one piece of equipment for
working out it'd probably be smart to go
with just wooden ring
because that there are that flexible and
you can do that much different stuff I
mean you can do dips you can do muscle
ups you can do pull-ups you can do
push-ups you do all kinds of stuff you
can do levers you can do front levers
back levers there's all kinds of
gymnastic moves you can do I mean you
could basically work for the rest of
your life on rings and be good to go so
rings are a way of handling the whole
pull up and dip bar situation but and
that's why it's pretty much the number
two thing for me is is pull-up bar dip
bar / rinks because those are all gonna
kind of get you those basic body
movements to build your strength once
you get past that now it's time for a
squat rack it's got to have a squat rack
and as soon as you have a squat rack now
my school my squat rack has a pull-up
bar on it which I bolted on myself my
squat rack is the same years of when I
bought my first house immediately had a
garage gym it was 20 I don't know 27
years ago or something like that built a
garage gym immediately bought a squat
rack still have the same squat rack
bolted a pull-up bar onto it still have
that I modified it a little bit and made
it bar so I had a dip bar on it this is
before you could buy gymnastic or so I
didn't know how to get a hold of
gymnastics rings back in those days and
then the next thing you need is you need
an Olympic lifting bar and and bumper
plates so you can do your squats your
cleans your clean and jerks your
deadlifts and all your basic strength
movements after that for me I think
kettlebells you know so now you have you
can do your swings you can do your
farmers walks you can do your snatches
you can I mean there's a ton of
exercises Turkish get-ups I mean there's
a ton of exercises that you can do there
that kettlebells now add to the
situation and you can use some really
psychotic conditioning metabolic
conditioning with the addition of
kettlebells as well at this point if you
only have one set of rings I have three
sets of rings and I have one that's high
for muscle ups I have one that's medium
for dips and I have one that's low for
for push-ups and I just have those all
the time so you have to adjust them
because I guess I'm too lazy to want to
adjust my rings all the time yeah the
next piece for me is I like rowers the
concept to rowers I have one I've had it
for a long time they're brutal workout I
think that you can just destroy yourself
very easily and very quickly
and I think like a like an Aerodyne or
an aerosol type bike I don't have one of
those I'm probably gonna get one very
soon but I think those are outstanding
as well I didn't say jump rope earlier
that's another good kind of cardio kind
of metcon kind of get after it and then
maybe some medicine balls and after that
I mean I think you know you that the
question was essential equipment to me
that's sort of my list yeah and then
from there it just becomes fun you know
it becomes what kind of other implements
can I bring into the situation that are
gonna eliminate boredom increase
creativity increased dynamic and
functional movement and I think these
these are pretty good